what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and
loki
episode 5 was truly amazing and it left
us with a lot to think about including
a lot more kang the conqueror easter
eggs but will king be revealed
in the loki series we know he's
confirmed to be coming in ant-man and
the wasp quantomania played by jonathan
magers but is kang the person
hiding in that castle that loki and
sylvie are about to infiltrate
or is it king loki after all the show is
about different
variants of loki it would kind of make
sense if in the finale the person behind
it all
was actually loki himself after all that
is what loki
is typically about ruling conquering
perhaps one version of loki
instead of just trying to conquer earth
conquered the entire
timeline and multiverse however like i
said we do have a lot more easter eggs
for
king the conqueror in this episode and
this is going to be my ending explained
and full
breakdown of loki episode 5 journey into
mystery and if you love the loki series
so far and the mcu be sure to subscribe
and hit that notification bell so you
don't miss out on any of the latest
videos
so we'll go ahead and start with the
ending explained because i know a lot of
people are wondering about this and then
we'll talk about who could be
inside of that mysterious castle then
i'll do a breakdown of the extremely
important events that happened in this
episode that you need to know
so what the ending explained as we start
off episode 5
ravona rinslayer explains that when they
prune a reality or a person it's
impossible to get rid of all of their
matter so instead they move it to a
place on the timeline where it won't
continue growing so when they were
resetting timelines throughout the loki
series they weren't actually resetting
timelines they were simply
moving the timelines transferring them
and they transfer it to a void
at the end of time where every instance
of existence collides at the same point
and simply stops now sylvie asks why it
stops but ravona says she doesn't know
however this is revealed to us by
the loki's as we go to the void where
loki was sent after he was pruned and
other loki's before him we learn about
the entity
eliath and eliath has the job of
permanently
deleting everybody so all of the
different timelines that get
pruned and all of the different people
that get pruned eliath permanently gets
rid of them and this is why
everything comes to an end but sylvie
asks what if you go
beyond the void judge rinslayer says
that the void
is the end of time and that the
timekeepers were supposedly
writing the end of time so the void is
as far as you can go
but sylvie thinks that you could push
past it because she believes that if you
go past it
that's where the person who created the
tva will be
so her plan is to get past eliath so she
prunes herself and she ends up in the
void she meets up with loki and the
other loki's and says that her plan is
to enchant it because when she first
arrived in the void she made contact
with eliath and connected with it
leading her to believe that she could
enchant it and then essentially remove
it out of her way
and find out who's behind everything so
that is exactly
what happens with the help of classic
loki a dagger from kid loki
and help from our main man tom
hiddleston loki himself
sylvie and loki together were able to
enchant
eliath and once they enchanted eliath
they removed eliath out of the picture
revealing a castle that looks to be in
the middle of the universe
now this was actually revealed to us in
a previous loki trailer you just had to
look
really really closely new rockstars
pointed out that if you took a look at
this
donut shaped rock on top of it you could
see sort of a golden yellow light
we see the same golden yellow light in
the castle that is revealed at the end
of episode 5.
the castle has a tower and at the top of
that tower is a golden
yellow light and if you look at the
background there is a
very very bright white line this is also
found in the other shot as well and this
is most likely the sacred
timeline and this castle is most likely
at the
end of time and whoever is so-called
riding
time or finishing the timeline is in
this castle
living right at the end of time and in
episode six the finale
sylvie and loki are going to confront
this person and now of course the big
question
is who is there and as i mentioned
before in the beginning
at this point we've narrowed it down to
pretty much two options
kang the conqueror or king loki a
different
variant of loki now there have been many
easter eggs and references to king the
conqueror all throughout the loki series
and keep in mind that kang the conqueror
is confirmed to be coming in the movie
ant-man and the wasp
quantum mania so it is confirmed that
his character is going to be introduced
into the mcu
soon perhaps he could make his debut in
loki because in the comics king the
conqueror
is from the future and is a master of
time travel
he would use his time travel devices and
go on to conquer many different
timelines
taking on the name kang the conqueror
but his real name is nathaniel richards
believed to be a descendant of reed
richards of the fantastic four
king the conqueror in the comics is
directly connected with the three
time keepers the three time keepers
actually seek out kang when they make it
to the end of time
they discover that they are the only
three people left so they go back to
time to kang and they make him an offer
instead of conquering different
timelines he could save them
and in return they would grant him
immortality kang accepts the deal and he
rebrands himself
as immortus obviously the three time
keepers
existing at the end of time are in loki
also
not to mention the void in loki where
everything kind of goes to die at the
end of time
is sort of a limbo and in the comics
that is the dimension
where kang dwells in a limbo dimension
that sort of exists outside of time
there is his base chronopolis and this
could be the castle that we are seeing
in loki they could have just rebranded
it a little bit from the comics instead
of it being an entire city
it's just a castle then not to mention
there is a
really specific easter egg at 3 minutes
into loki episode 5. you can see the old
avengers tower
on the right but instead of saying stark
or avengers it says
q-e-n-g and if you pronounce that
it actually does sound kind of like keng
however this
is an actual company and get this king
himself
actually owns this company kang the
conqueror finds himself displaced in
time and stuck in the 21st century
so while he's stuck there he decides to
make the best of it taking on the name
of mr gryffin he buys the stark tower
from tony stark
and the company that he owns is q-e-n-g
and he puts it on the side this is what
we are seeing here this is a direct
easter egg to nathaniel richards aka
kang so a huge easter egg here and not
to mention ravona rinslayer or judge
rinslayer who has been
in the loki series since episode 1 is
kang's lover in the comics so there are
just a ton of easter eggs pointing
towards kang the conqueror however
the series is the loki series it's
focused on loki and it wouldn't be a
surprise to me at all
if that at the end it was loki behind it
all
it was loki all along loki has always
wanted to rule and as he mentioned in
the beginning of the series
he would rule to make it easier for
people and like he said in the first
avengers film
is this not simpler so it is entirely
in loki's nature to somehow manage to
get a hold of a sacred timeline and kind
of do with it
what he wants and feels is best and in
the comics there is actually
a king loki which is a future loki
and long story short he kind of decides
to do things on his own
and make destiny what he believes it
should be and that has been a
reoccurring theme
in the series loki has struggled with
destiny and fate when mobius told him
that
he dies by thanos every time because
that is what's supposed to happen
loki has a big problem with this because
loki wants to create his own future and
that could be
what a variant of loki did so we've
narrowed it down to
a king loki or kang now what could
happen
is that it could be loki but loki could
be working for
kang and kang could be the next thanos
and just like
loki in our main timeline was working
for thanos it could be the same thing
here but this loki could be working for
kang
or perhaps they could throw us off and
it could be he
who remains he who remains in the comics
is the final director of the time
variance authority and he exists at the
citadel at the end of time the last
reality of the multiverse
and it's pretty clear that this castle
exists at the end of time
although i don't think it's he who
remains but they could throw us a
curveball so at this point in time i'm
betting that it's kang
or loki and be sure to let me know who
you think it is
in the comments down below and now let's
break down these key moments of what
happened in episode 5
journey into mystery now we start off by
being reminded what happened at the end
of loki episode 4 we see one of the
fake timekeepers heads on the floor we
know that loki got pruned and mobius got
pruned but we know that loki didn't
actually die
and from here we get a glimpse of the
city that he is in it is a broken down
destroyed city and it starts to zoom in
on loki from afar
kind of taking us through the city here
we see the avengers tower that has
q-e-n-g on it
and then we finally arrive to loki and
the other loki's and there's a bus on
the left
and we can see a name on the bus and
that name is column
ross and callum ross is actually an
editor for the loki series so tiny
little easter egg there
here loki asks the other loki's three
questions
what is this place where are we who are
you in which classic loki replies
this is the void that's a lieth and
where is lunch now as i mentioned before
rinslayer explained that timelines that
are reset are actually just
transferred same with people that are
pruned from there eliath permanently
destroys them in fact it's the very next
scene where she explains this to sylvie
and she says that she
actually wants to know who is behind the
tva because she claims to not know as
well and she claims that they lied to
her
although this is kind of hard to believe
because she wasn't really that shocked
when she found out that the time keepers
were androids so it definitely seemed
like she knew
but meanwhile loki is traveling with the
other loki's trying to escape
eliath and they basically explain the
same thing that ravona says
everything the tva prunes ends up there
at that void
entire branched timelines end up there
and get devoured by elia
in an instant and their job right now is
essentially to stay alive
from here it's revealed that that
alligator is indeed a loki variant which
loki accepts pretty easily because
why not but he wonders why there are so
many loki's and as classic loki explains
because
that's what they do they survive and
they basically state that there's no way
back
except for a temp pad which of course
they could never get their hands on
because nobody from the tva
actually goes to the void but here we
actually find out why
kid loki is the commander of the group
loki asks him
why do you wear the horns and you let a
child command you
in which classic loki replies you'll do
well to respect the boy
it's his kingdom and we find out that
his nexus event was him
killing thor now here we see them walk
to their hidden base and there are a few
really cool easter eggs one we can see
a giant helmet of the evil villain
yellowjacket the villain from the first
ant-man film
then we see a super awesome easter egg
the thanos copter
the thanos copter comes from the very
old comic arc
the cat and the cosmic cube in which
thanos actually uses the thanos copter
to try
and obtain the cosmic cube and he
doesn't succeed he actually gets
arrested in handcuffs which is funny to
think about because
of how powerful he would go on to be in
the comics and in the mcu
then the loki's start to go underground
and we kind of pan
through the dirt in which we see mjolnir
and the frog
version of thor in a jar trying to get
mjolnir this
is known as throg in the comics and yes
in the comics throgg does indeed wield
mjolnir
now from here we go back to sylvie and
rinslayer rinslayer explains the void
and this is where silvie has the idea to
go
beyond the void once they go beyond the
void they find the person that created
the tva and kill them
together rinslayer leads sylvie to
believe that she actually does want to
take down whoever
made the tva but at the same time she
calls in reinforcements but eventually
sylvie prunes herself to get to the void
so she can team up with loki and try to
get past it we then meet up with the
loki's again and beau sveloki is going
on about how he defeated captain america
and
iron man however alligator loki calls
him a liar
and he doesn't exactly try to fight with
him about the fact
but then we find out that alligator
loki's nexus event was eating the wrong
neighbor's cat so he was supposed to eat
a neighbor's cat he just ate the wrong
one
they fight for a second but then here is
where we find out something
extremely important our lucky was led to
believe that he had to go on
and die at the hands of thanos thanos
chokes him to death and snaps his neck
in infinity war but this is not what
happened for classic loki he tells
arloki that their magic potential is a
lot more than they think it is and the
daggers that they use
actually stunt the potential his magic
was so strong that he cast an illusion
so strong that even thanos the mad titan
believed it so thanos thought he killed
the real loki but it was just an
illusion while the other loki hid
he floated in space for a while and then
landed upon a planet eventually he
missed his brother and everybody else
and decided to leave the planet and
right when he decided to leave the tva
showed up but the big story here
is that this loki did not die by thanos
and perhaps
our loki didn't die at the hands of
thanos either
perhaps our loki did the same thing cast
a very strong illusion
this could have huge implications for
the future of the mcu
and you never really know with marvel
this could have been their plan the
entire time
from here loki decides that he has to go
back to the tva and he has to get sylvie
kid loki notices that arloki is a little
bit different but loki exclaims that
it's not him that's different
but it's actually sylvie and loki's plan
to get back since eliath keeps them
there
is to kill elia then which the other
loki's laugh at him but he decides to
leave anyways now there's a little cool
easter egg in this scene there's a
polyvias arcade machine
in loki's lair the polybs game was an
urban legend concerting a fictitious
1980s arcade game
it was a game that was supposedly funded
by the government as
a crowdsourced psychology experiment the
game supposedly produced intense
psychoactive and addictive effects in
the player
and this is implying that in the mcu
it's real or at least in some timelines
it was
now as loki leaves he is greeted by
president loki
and president loki's posse now not all
of these people with president loki are
loki variants because as the other
loki's explained they've never seen a
girl
variant of a loki and there is a girl
with president loki but it does look
like most of them are indeed variants as
some
variants that we saw in episode 2 appear
here with president loki
from here we cut to sylvie and she is
getting chased by eliath but
luckily mobius is still alive and saves
her
and a couple easter eggs here as they're
driving trying to escape alaiaf we can
see
a sphynx and the sphinx at one point in
time is actually a spaceship
that kang uses to travel through time it
also looks like we can see
the stonehenge on the right side in the
same scene in which you kind of wonder
what the sphinx and the stonehenge did
to end up in the void now back with the
loki's we find out that boastful loki
actually led president loki and his army
to kid loki's lair
he did this because he had to deal with
president loki he would get his army but
of course
loki being loki he betrayed him and then
the other loki variants
being loki they betrayed president loki
in which an all-out war kind of breaks
out thanks to alligator loki biting the
hand
off of president loki but it works out
because this is how our loki alligator
loki
kid loki and classic loki escape from
here classic loki
is pretty pissed he says loki's we lie
we cheat and kid loki says and whenever
we try to change
we end up here and this is where loki
says that's why they gotta take down the
tva
and that's why they need the help of
sylvie so they have to take down
goliath and the loki's agree to help
meanwhile mobius
and sylvie reconcile and determine the
only way to really press forward and to
see who's behind the tva
is to go take down eliath as well so
they head towards the big cloud
now kid loki actually has some sort of a
device that predicts when the next reset
timeline
is going to jump into the void in which
they go and they find the 173
uss eldridge which has a pretty
interesting story in real life known as
the philadelphia experiment it was a
military experiment that claims to have
made
the ship invisible or cloaked to enemy
devices but there was a lot of
controversy to this
and it was never proven and it doesn't
really bode too well for them in the
void either as
eliath comes and quickly destroys them
but then mobius and sylvie meet up with
arloki
and the other loki's in which they come
up with their master plan of
enchanting alive to get past it now from
here we find out that hunter b15
is still alive and being held prisoner
ravona rinslayer then questions her
about sylvie and here we learn the truth
and that is that rinslayer actually
wants to know who's behind the tva
as well leading us to believe that maybe
she didn't really know who was in charge
but hunter b15 explains that it doesn't
matter because sylvie is going to get to
the timekeeper creator before
her but that doesn't stop rinse layer
from doing some digging on the founding
of the tva
and when it started then we go back to
the loki's and mobius in which we have
some very important scenes
one is mobius talking to alligator loki
classic loki
and kid loki he claims that when he goes
back to the tva he wants to tell
everybody the truth and classic loki
states that he's just going to turn his
back on what he devoted his life to and
mobius drops the bomb
stating that it's never too late to
change and this is something that our
loki
and these other loki's have struggled
with they want to change but some feel
like it's too
late we then have loki and silvi kind of
tiptoeing around the fact that they're
both in love with each other slash
themselves and we see a little bit of
their narcissism coming out when they
say
that bringing down the tva is
essentially saving the universe
the two of them bond snuggle a little
bit and promise not to betray each other
stating that
loki has actually changed and then the
two of them basically make plans that
when after the tv is gone they'll kind
of go do something together maybe
have their own timeline together which i
think is something that everybody wants
at this point
now from here the loki's and mobius
unite sylvia is going to go enchant
eliath and loki decides to stay
with her then kid loki and classic loki
decide that they want to stay there in
the void as well because
that's their home that's all they've
really known for a long time now sylvie
and loki trust mobius and they give him
the temp pad
and kid loki gives r loki his super
awesome and looks to be extremely
magical dagger essentially turning loki
into harry potter
classic loki and kid loki leave and we
have an insanely good scene between
mobius and loki where they say goodbye
mobius says that he's gonna burn the tva
to the ground just like loki said he was
going to do mobius reaches for the
handshake but loki goes in for the hug
calling him his friend and mobius says
that he was his favorite
he then goes through the temp portal and
leaves and from here we get
our final scene loki and silvi need a
branch to happen so that eliath will
focus on it however a branch doesn't end
up happening in time
eliath is focused on them so they need a
distraction loki goes into harry potter
mode but isn't exactly the best wizard
and can't cause a great enough
distraction
however classic loki can and his magic
is so outstanding and powerful that he
literally creates an illusion of the
entirety
of asgard his home that he once knew
and eliath takes the bait unfortunately
this ends in classic loki's doom however
it shows loki and silvi that they're
actually a lot stronger
than they think they are and the two of
them together hand in hand
are able to actually enchant eliath
revealing the castle behind it
which has the person who created the tva
and controls the timeline
inside of it and that's where we're left
and no post-credits scene which was
rather odd
now a lot of people are saying that this
kind of looks like doom's castle and i
would have to agree
however do not expect doctor doom to
show up yes he is an incredibly powerful
sorcerer but remember
this show is about loki so it's most
likely another variant of loki or kang
inside of this castle and as i mentioned
in the beginning be sure
to let me know who you think is inside
loki
or king and be sure to let me know what
you would rate this episode of loki
episode 5 from 1 to 10 in the comments
down below 10 of course being the
highest rating
don't forget to subscribe so you don't
miss out on any of the latest loki
videos or mcu news don't forget to like
the video and for live updates you can
always follow me on
instagram and twitter as always thank
you all so much for watching
woof